psychiatry has always had a complex
relationship to trauma it started off as
a discipline that looked at the bizarre
Simpson that people have and then he
uncovered way back in the late 1800s to
sub etar in paris particularly that
people have very bizarre reactions to to
trauma and so just that define hysteria
150 years ago and so there were some
interested and then they put a
compassionate people no longer a large
study hysteria first world war breaks
out a huge number of traumatized guys
have the same symptoms at his women
people come home for the first war have
a terrible experience they're all being
accused of malingering very traumatized
people probably had a lot to do with the
rise of Nazism
and eventually Second World War a lot of
effort second world war and then in 1947
the last book about war trauma gets
published and there is nothing till 1982
or something so it takes a long time and
even when I was a student the my
textbook said that incest is extremely
rare and it is really good for people
and it doesn't really cause any major
damage because it gives women and girls
permission to do something that this
video forbidden but eventually protects
their mental health and so there has
been a long-term difficult Lexx
relationship versus versus Akaya tree
really doesn't want to see trauma and in
the current DSM the people call the
bible of psychiatry where my colleagues
and I at the National Child traumatic
stress Network Network worked very hard
to get a diagnosis and to make room for
their hundreds of thousands if not
millions of kids who get abused and
neglected to his parents go off to jail
I was Paris a drug addicts who bears are
not there for them and then being grown
up we try to get diagnosis in called
development the term a disorder
and the response was after submitting
data on 20,000 children with this
problem they said oh we don't really
have enough evidence for this nish
diagnosis and in fact vast majority are
sick section 2 care are in fact
traumatize human beings so now now we
live with via diagnoses like
oppositional defiant disorder where
people don't ask why did these kids come
become defiant or conduct disorder than
these kids behave strangely with bipolar
disorder kids being mentally unstable
going up and down and their emotions and
people don't really doesn't really want
to look at what's behind there and as a
consequence instead of looking at social
conditions as being at the origin of
these disorders these kids get drugged
up last year in the u.s. kids got 18
point 1 billion dollars worth of
psychotropic drugs and these drugs
actually do calm people down but they
also work on the reward system in the
brain and decrease curiosity openness
experimentation engagement with people
and I am extremely concerned that all
these medicated children in America are
likely to grow up having a deficit in
that capacity to engage deficit in the
capacity to learn to be original to be
engaged to be a useful member of the
workforce so that today the neglect of
the issue of trauma in the u.s. in
particular is a very serious public
health issue
you